- [Chris In Black Shirt] Do you have a lot
of stuff in there?
- [Man In Gray Shirt] A lot.
- [Chris] Do you mind if I rap
about stuff that's in there?
- [Man In Gray Shirt] Absolutely.
- [Chris] Okay, tell me when you got it.
- [Man In Gray Shirt] Got it.
- [Chris] Cool.
(background rap beat)
♪ First thing I was amazed ♪
♪ When I got the lime green on
the interior of the shades ♪
♪ Can I see the brand passing to my hand ♪
♪ Let me say made by Carolina Lemke ♪
♪ A brand I've never heard of ♪
♪ Not the Ray-Ban ♪
♪ But that's okay we put
it on like a spray tan ♪
♪ Little set of headphones
easy to handle ♪
♪ But dude gotta make sure
they are less tangled ♪
♪ Let me fix these for you ♪
♪ Now you owe me ♪
♪ They feel kinda lightweight ♪
♪ An off-brand Sony ♪
♪ And what the heck is this ♪
♪ Ahh, I respect ♪
♪ McDonald Army Community
Hospital coin check ♪
(girl laughing)
♪ You can tap it on the table ♪
♪ Gotta buy a round ♪
♪ Got the nice enamel on
the side and the sound ♪
♪ In recognition of
being an excellent guy ♪
♪ And here's a battery pack ♪
♪ I say me oh my ♪
♪ Every guy's phone in
the town can get charged ♪
♪ Why 'cause the amps in
your battery large: 20,800 ♪
♪ Let me say you over 9,000 like Goku ♪
♪ Now this 'Secured Roofing and Resto' ♪
♪ Put it on your hands
and all the pests go ♪
♪ All the germs they be
dropping off and go away ♪
♪ 'Licensed and Insured' call
Secured Restoration today ♪
♪ What's the number ♪
♪ Starts with three, five, two ♪
♪ Hara-Kiri let me knife Seppuku ♪
♪ Why it's the land of the rising sun ♪
♪ Call Japan Nipponese I'm arrivin' ♪
♪ I slip on these like
a set of wet leaves ♪
♪ A nasty surgical mask oh geez ♪
♪ Please take this shit away from me ♪
♪ It's like one-ply thickness ♪
♪ It don't do many ♪
♪ This yes ♪
♪ If your lungs need a juice ♪
♪ Get the O2 in there call it a boost ♪
♪ Natural flavor ♪
♪ Oh in the eye ♪
♪ In the atmosphere you can see it ♪
♪ Pocket size altitude
and poor air quality ♪
♪ Like a respirator or a pot of tea ♪
♪ And this one get your breath fresh ♪
♪ When you're in a pinch ♪
♪ Fishermen's Friend and you've got ♪
♪ The Spearmint ♪
♪ But you've gotta ask why ♪
♪ It's written in Thai
or maybe Vietnamese ♪
♪ I don't know my eye ain't
fixed to their language ♪
♪ Yeah go to slip ♪
Cosmo in Vegas Baccarat chip ♪
♪ That's a hundred dollars ♪
♪ Yeah you're totally able
to take it to the cage ♪
♪ You stole this from the table ♪
(group laughs)
♪ Why didn't you return
them at the booth ♪
♪ Here's a little pen
to tell you the truth ♪
♪ It's a Pilot but it's not fly ♪
♪ Why 'cause it costs $2.99 ♪
♪ Very cheap when it
comes to roller ball ♪
♪ I fit the joint
checking that or wallet ♪
♪ Bye-Bye I'm going ♪
♪ Anyway let me return it ♪
♪ Not hard ♪
♪ Appreciate the wallet I
ain't taking the cards ♪
♪ Any other things that we got in there ♪
♪ Just a little thing ♪
♪ Yeah I'm totally aware ♪
♪ Dettol wipes you're gonna
need them after this rhyme ♪
♪ Because I touched it and
my hands slick with grime ♪
♪ Like the beat that we go and I say ♪
♪ Is it a Euro from the UK ♪
♪ Nah it's a little dollar ♪
There, the beat's gone.
There we go.
(group laughing)
- [Chris] If you would like a Chris Turner
hat or face mask, they're on
sale now at GoodSirLA.com.
- [Woman] Welcome to 2020, honey...
- [Chris] We're rhymin' about
whatever you got in your bag
So keep your things coming.
This is gonna be great.
Cool.
(rap background beat)
♪ Dropping rhymes,
calling me the spit boss ♪
♪ I like this two types of lip gloss ♪
♪ Asking everybody what do you think ♪
♪ This shade or this shade ♪
♪ Both of them are pink ♪
♪ I don't even know the difference ♪
♪ It's feeling kinda silly
♪ ♪ You could film it ♪
♪ We'd be filming too I'm gettin' busy ♪
♪ Lip sleeping mask ♪
♪ What the heck ♪
♪ Do you apply it to your
lips ♪ ♪ Why not a neck ♪
♪ I get that people don't want
any wrinkles right there ♪
♪ But lips ♪
♪ 'Oh they're too dry' I don't care ♪
♪ It's still a kiss ♪
♪ Either way feeling pretty good ♪
♪ And what else is in there ♪
♪ Yeah look under the hood - Jeff ♪
♪ You can get some things
out for us you can show ♪
♪ Rummagin' in her little
purse and we know ♪
♪ Why the heck is there so many I say ♪
♪ Eye shadow primer Urban Decay ♪
♪ Probably expensive I
should just run away ♪
♪ There you return it ♪
♪ Have nicer lips today ♪
♪ And these things Ray-Ban ♪
♪ Not false ordered from Thailand ♪
♪ Me and my man looking cool
when we're rocking the UV ♪
♪ Put it right back there
you're such a beauty ♪
♪ Any other things ♪
♪ What you're gonna
give get it out there ♪
♪ Got the hole like a sieve ♪
♪ It's a mask you be
holdin' it like a dog turd ♪
♪ Weirdest little blue
thing that I ever heard ♪
♪ And this keep your breath
fresh when you spit ♪
♪ How many pieces in
there most of the Orbit ♪
♪ Winter mint remains ♪
♪ So your bad breath
doesn't ever need to stay ♪
♪ It's got a little logo ♪
♪ Saying throw this away ♪
♪ Any other thing ♪
♪ Are you enjoying this today ♪
♪ It's just a cup of water ♪
♪ Maybe a cocktail ♪
♪ Has it got the alcohol ♪
♪ Yeah you won't reveal that ♪
♪ Don't tell us you won't speak truth ♪
♪ Annoying bus noise
but that's okay whoo! ♪
- [Chris] Thanks for watching.
Please do Like and Subscribe
and check out another one
of my freestyle videos.